bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux alors j'interromps un peu la
diffusion de un jour un fossile parce
qu'il ya des ja du nouveau qui se passe
il ya de l'actualité brûlante qui a
besoin d'être commentées et il m'a été
demandé de commenter à propos de cette
actualité et cette actualité c'est
évidemment cet article qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui article qui clame que
l'origine de l'humanité
c'est dans le titre je veux dire
l'origine de l'humanité se trouverait au
sud de l'afrique
voilà et donc étant moi-même
paléontologues en afrique du sud est et
en moi même pas trop pas trop coûteux b
à propos du sujet de l'origine et de
l'évolution humaine
eh bien je pense être compétent pour
pouvoir commenter un petit peu cette
actualité encore que il va quand même
falloir que je mette des limites à cette
compétence
un petit disclaimer un petit comment des
déclarations de conflits d'intérêts
voilà on va appeler ça une déclaration
de conflit d'intérêts donc premier
conflit d'intérêts d'une je suis
moi-même chercheurs en afrique du sud
donc quand un article parle de l'origine
humaine dans le sud de l'afrique
ben évidemment mon petit coeur se pince
évidemment que évidemment que je suis
sensible à ça donc donc donc ça peut
influencer mon objectivité encore que je
ne pense pas que dans ce cas là ça le
fera parce que j'ai déjà lu l'article
donc évidemment je veux pas le découvrir
je vais pas le découvrir devant vous je
vais vous expliquer ce que j ai vu et
et pourquoi pourquoi je pense ce que je
pense à propos de cet article mais bon
là dans ce cas là je pense que ça va mon
objectivité devrait être ok de ce point
de vue la deuxième chose c'est que je ne
suis ni paléoanthropologue ni généticien
et là en l'occurrence c'est que de la
paléoanthropologie et de la génétique
c'est surtout de la génétique d'ailleurs
donc donc donc je vais où je vais
commenter cet article
en n'étant pas trop con sur le sujet
mais quand même dans la limite de mes
compétences et donc et ça va aussi
limiter mes compétences quant à répondre
à vos questions si jamais vous avez des
questions dans les commentaires
voilà donc donc après ce petit
disclaimer je pense qu'on peut commencer
donc l'origine humaine au sud de
l'afrique comment qui sont arrivés à
cette conclusion nos amis nos amis qui
sont principalement coréens alors il ya
quelques sud africain dans le tas mais
alors c'est des sud africains dont j'ai
rarement vu passer le nom à mon avis et
des sud africains qui se sont
kiki ceux qui ont été inclus dans
l'article parce qu'ils ont donné accès à
des données pas tellement parce qu'ils
ont dû y contribuer activement à cette
recherche
mais honnêtement j'en sais rien mais
c'est essentiellement des coréens les
auteurs donc comment on arrive à la
conclusion que l'humanité est originaire
d'afrique et bah c'est assez simple
c'est le résultat le plus gros résultat
qu'ils ont c'est cet arbre
phylogénétique et cet arbre
phylogénétique c'est donc un arbre
phylogénétique de gênes mitochondriaux
humain donc les gènes des mitochondries
humaine les petites mitochondries
sceller les usines à gaz de votre de
votre organisme c'est ça qui vous donne
de l'énergie et donc on trouve à la base
de cet arbre est bien les populations
donc qu'on trouve au sud de l'afrique
ici donc envers en bleu en bleu foncé et
puis on dans des niveaux de bleu et de
vert plus clair celle qui se trouve
légèrement plus au nord là et puis après
plus on s'éloigne de la racine de la
roue et plus
alors au début on est au milieu du sud
de l'afrique et puis après on s'écarte
plus vers le sud et plus vers le nord
voyez donc en fait quand on parcourt cet
arbre on a presque eu cette sensation
voilà de se trouver au milieu de
l'afrique voilà et puis de s'écarter
ensuite
vers vers le nord et vers le sud donc
d'où cette idée que finalement le
l'humanité serait originaire de la voilà
donc au nord du zambèze dans au botswana
quoi et qu'ensuite il y aurait eu des
mouvements de dispersion vers l'afrique
de l'est et vers l'afrique du sud
le tout étant daté de 200 mille ans
voilà donc on utilise l'horloge
moléculaire on sait combien il ya une
mutation qui se sont produites on sait
le temps qu'il faut pour qu'une mutation
ait lieu donc on peut appliquer une
horloge moléculaire c'est le principe de
la vitesse égale distance sur temps la
distance c'est la mutation le temps
c'est le temps entre les mutations et on
date tout ça d'à peu près de cent de
toute cette divergence d'à peu près de
cent mille ans qui vous donne une
origine humaine à 200 mille ans qui
était globalement là où se trouvait le
consensus jusqu'à présent donc on trouve
un résultat qui est pas dégoûtant et
puis bon on dit du coup que le
l'humanité est originaire de ce coin là
de l'afrique donc du sud de l'afrique
à partir de ces données que cette
origine date d'il ya deux cent mille ans
voilà d'où sortent ces résultats et
après vous avez peut-être vu dans la
presse qu'ils avaient toutes un
babillage à propos de des conditions
climatiques etc
bon bah c'est tous et il trouve que
l'origine humaine à 200 mille ans enfin
que l'humain que l'être humain est
apparu il ya deux cent mille ans dans ce
coin-là de l'afrique il essaye de voir
si le climat était potable à l'époque et
puis bien évidemment il trouve que oui
puisqu'il y avait forcément un coin
enfin vous avez vu l'étendue
géographique de ce truc là
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
moitié du botswana il ya forcément un
endroit où le climat devait être potable
dans ce coin là il ya deux cent mille
ans donc voilà c'est un peu ça et puis
après ils essaient de trouver des routes
de dispersion on sait qu'il ya entre 200
et 100 mille ans et qu'il ya plein de
variations climatiques qui peuvent avoir
amené créer des langues de forêt enfin
de savane et de forêts qui était
praticable et qui pouvait permettre la
dispersion à partir de là donc voilà il
ya un gros babillage sur le climat tout
ça pour dire que c'est possible qu'ils
aient eu des humains cet endroit là il
ya deux cent mille ans et que c'est très
possible qu'ensuite ils se soient mis à
voyager
donc ça c'est le coeur de l'article
maintenant c'est l'heure de la critique
salée c'est l'heure des épices
c'est l'heure du boudin créole ça pique
le boudin créole je sais pas si vous
avez déjà essayé mais ça pique
et donc donc donc bas quel est le
problème avec cet article déjà un ferrer
une origine au sud de l'afrique
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord les
données pointent clairement par là je
veux dire il ya il ya quelques crânes
humains qui ont été trouvés en afrique
de l'est mais qui sont assez archaïque
pour la plupart ils ont des gros bourg
les suces orbitaire
il ya un crâne humain qui a été trouvé
en afrique du nord mais il a un énorme
boulet sur son orbiteur et il n'a pas de
menton donc c'est très peu de chances
d'être un homo sapiens moderne et il y a
et il y a le crâne de blum font pas de
bloemfontein de floris bad mais qui se
trouve au musée de bloemfontein en
afrique du sud
et ce crâne de floris bad je vous en
avais parlé dans le dans un palais aux
news récent il est il a été analysé il a
été analysé sa morphologie en fait
reflète exactement la morphologie qu'on
s'attend à trouver chez l'ancêtre commun
de tous les êtres humains et il se
trouve qu'il a deux cent soixante mille
ans donc ça colle relativement bien avec
ce qu'on a là donc que ya un faisceau de
preuves qui est tout à fait correct et
puis évidemment vous avez les plus
anciennes populaire enfin les
populations humaines qui ont divergé le
plus tôt dans l'arbre génétique humain
ce sont les causes and et les pygmées
qui vivent justement dans la moitié sud
de l'afrique dans ces régions-là donc
tous à sa pointe assez clairement du
doigt l'afrique du le sud de l'afrique
comme étant un centre d'origine
important pour l'humanité et j'ai
presque envie d'utiliser le mot berceau
de l'humanité parce que je sais que ça
va en faire râler certains
donc voilà le berceau de l'humanité dans
la moitié sud de l'afrique
moi ça me choque pas très honnêtement on
a les preuves
enfin je veux dire les voilà on a des
preuves génétiques avec les populations
les plus divergentes de l'humanité qui
est qui viennent de par là on a
divergentes génétiquement évidemment me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit on à
des fossiles qui reflète assez bien ce
qu'on s'attend à trouver chez l'ancêtre
commun de l'humanité à cet endroit là
donc a priori
moi ça me choque pas maintenant quand on
veut montrer que l'origine de l'humanité
là comme c'était le cas dans le titre
quand on veut montrer que l'origine du
mail de l'humanité se trouve au sud de
l'afrique
on essaye déjà d'avoir un échantillon
qui va au delà du sud de l'afrique
parce qu'évidemment la regarder le haut
d'où viennent leurs échantillons
voilà l'origine géographique de leurs
des mythos génome donc des génomes
mitochondriaux qu'ils ont analysé bah
oui forcément si leur échantillonnage et
limiter strictement à la moitié sud de
l'afrique
on risque pas de trouver autre chose que
qu'une origine au sud de l'afrique
donc ça c'est le premier truc qui me
dérange avec ceux avec cette étude c'est
l'échantillonnage
si vous regardez pas ailleurs qu'au sud
de l'afrique vous trouverez pas ailleurs
qu'au dessus de l'afrique
donc ça c'est un premier problème le
deuxième problème que j'ai avec cette
étude
c'est cet arbre là donc ça c'est l'arbre
qui a dans l'article mais cet arbre qui
a dans l'article c'est une version
simplifiée d'un autre arbre qui se
trouvent dans les données
supplémentaires qu'ils se trouvent après
l'article
et oui c'est une des subtilités quand on
publie l'ancien sénateur les les vraies
données intéressantes sont après
l'article pas dans l'article
et alors là c'est plus du tout la même
sauce regarder ça c'est l'arbre
phylogénétique donc le vrai pas la
version simplifiée et il ya un truc tout
con hein tout à l'heure ce qu'on a vu en
fait c'est une version simplifiée de
cette portion de l'arbre la cette
portion là hélas que vous voyez c'est ce
qu'on appelle la racine avec le groupe
externe qui se trouvent ici groupes
externes qui est populaire où on voit
des populations sibérienne russe
européenne de manière générale
sibérienne et européennes donc en gros
ce que vous avez c'est les populations
du sud de l'afrique contre le reste du
monde
ici donc en fait cet arbre ce n'est pas
un arbre la portion de l'arbre qu'on
nous montre là dans la lah dans
l'article c'est pas une phylogénie
humaine attendez je le retrouve 3 2 1
voilà je suis dessus donc cet arbre là
en fait c'est pas un arbre
phylogénétique de l'humanité c'est juste
un arbre phylogénétique des gens au sud
de l'afrique c'est tout c'est donc cette
origine il ya deux cent mille ans c'est
pas l'âge de divergences de l'humanité
c'est l'âge de divergence des
populations du sud de l'afrique et en
l'occurrence
le et en l'occurrence quand on lit
l'article en fait on se rend compte que
cet article n'a pas commencé comme une
étude visant à décrypter quelle était
l'origine de l'humanité
c'est une étude d'amis taudin haplotype
mitochondrial qui s'appelle laplaud type
l0 l0 donc qui caractérise les
populations notamment kohistan donc
l'école san ce sont ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement les bushmen
voilà donc c'est en fait cette étude
elle a commencé enfin ça se lit entre
les lignes de ce de l'article que cette
étude elle a juste commencé comme étant
une analyse génétique déco ihsane et des
populations qui en sont qui sont
apparentés donc cet arbre phylogénétique
c'est juste l'arbre phylogénétique déco
et san et des populations qui sont
apparentés et 7h de divergences de 200
mille ans c'est juste l'âge de
divergence déco et sané des populations
apparentés donc c'est juste un petit
bout de la variation humaine qui
échantillonnés ici et pas du tout la
totalité de la variation humaine et
surtout quand on considère qu'en afrique
il y a il ya eu la quasi-totalité de la
variabilité génétique humaine se trouve
en afrique donc donc quand on néglige
quand on est donc là cette analyse
génétique qui prétend parler des
origines de l'humanité en fait elle ne
parle que de l'origine d'un petit bout
de l'humanité que sont les co et san
voilà et tout le reste de la variabilité
génétique bas à prout voilà prout prout
d'ailleurs ils ont bien pris soin enfin
ils ont bien pris soin en tout cas
d'après ce qu'on voit de sur cet arbre
phylogénétique là ils ont pas pris de
populations qui viennent d'ailleurs qui
ne sont pas des ailes 0 voyez qu'ils
sont tous els 0l 0 sél haplotype
kohistan par excellence ils ont pas pris
d'autres haplotype donc du coup vous
avez comme groupes externes les
européens alors que normalement les
européens sont censés être juste un
petit bout de variabilité génétique des
du reste des populations africaines donc
laplaud type l3 normalement
donc en gros ba ba donc en gros ils ont
pas ils ont pas ce qu'il faut pour faire
cette affirmation là qui est
l'affirmation de leurs titres voilà
human origins innocents en afrique
mais bon comme il enfonce une porte
ouverte parce qu'ils le disent dans
l'introduction regarder le ligne la
ligne est elle 0 et celle qui prédomine
dans l'afrique du sud
enfin dans le sud de l'afrique devrais
je dire et on sait déjà qu'il n'ya pas
de co et san qui ont été retrouvées
ailleurs que dans la moitié sud de
l'afrique donc on sait déjà que l'écho
et sane c'est ce qu'ils divergent les
premiers voilà on sait déjà que c'est ce
qu'on trouve dans le sud de l'afrique et
on sait déjà qu'on ne trouve pas
ailleurs que dans le sud de l'afrique
donc ouais c'est ce que je disais c'est
un peu un serpent qui se mord la queue
en fait est ce que est ce que je suis
plutôt d'accord avec une origine
sud-africaine de l'humanité oui
globalement je suis d'accord parce qu'on
a quand même pas mal de preuve bon même
si après il faut quand même considéré
qu'il y avait plusieurs spécimens
archéologiques qui indique une origine
qui pourrait aussi indiquer une origine
est à free et est-africaine d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs vous allez hop
ici ils en parlent il ya aussi des
restes arqués archéologiques et
paléontologique qui suggèrent qu'ils
peuvent suggérer une origine de homo
sapiens dans l'est de l'afrique donc
l'un comme l'autre me choque pas quoi
mais c'est juste là pour le coup ce cet
article n'a pas le matos qu'il faut pour
faire les affirmations qu'il qui
l'affirment mais parce qu'il ya un mais
et là c'est un gros mais il faut aussi
appliquer une critique aux critiques qui
ont été appliquées à ces sur cet article
donc notamment notamment un article qui
a été publié dans la recherche est qui
et qui propose une critique qui est
quasiment une redite d'un article qui a
été publié dans la revue sayan ce qui
critique est ce enfin dans le magazine
sayan c'est qu'ils critiquaient cette
cette étude
et là ils ont repris plus ou moins les
mêmes arguments dans cet article qui a
été publié dans le magazine la recherche
donc dans le magazine la recherche on
nous propose donc une étude de cette une
critique de cette étude qui propose une
origine humaine dans le sud de l'afrique
est le premier truc que j'ai à critiquer
déjà c'est qu'ils font appel à
jean-jacques hublin pour la première
pour le premier et contre-arguments donc
jean jacques hublin qui évidemment
rappelle qu'on trouve les plus vieux
fossiles d'homo sapiens à 300 mille ans
au maroc
c'est à dire que là il aurait peut-être
dû commencer justement par un disclaimer
et une déclaration de conflit d'intérêts
parce que pour le coup c'est pas pour
rien qu'ils en parlent vu que c'est lui
qui a publié sa voix là c'est son bébé à
lui l'homo sapiens 10 à 300 mille ans là
quand on regarde les gènes le truc c'est
qu'on parle pas d'homo sapiens archaïque
on parle d' homo sapiens anatomiquement
modernes parce que tous les êtres
humains modernes sont des homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes sont homos
sapiens 10 à 300 mille ans n'y est pas
il n'est pas impossible qu'il soit homo
sapiens archaïque et il est encore et il
est même pas encore complètement sûr que
ce soit pas d'ailleurs un néandertal
puisqu'il ya des études récentes qui je
le rappelle encore une fois vous pouvez
vous référer au paléo new skies est
sorti récemment le titre du paléo news
c'est du nouveau sur les homininés et
vous verrez je parle de dents d'un
article qui justement retrouver ce
fameux fossiles de djebel est rude
parmi les néandertal et pas parmi les
les homo sapiens donc voyez bon il
prêche pour sa chapelle ce qui est
normal mais mais voilà il y aurait
peut-être fallu une petite déclaration
de conflit d'intérêts avant de de
publier sa est pour vous qu il irait ça
voilà ne prenez pas ça forcément pour
argent comptant il ya ya ya ya des
choses derrière il se passe des choses
derrière
après il ya d'autres autorités comme
français francesco d'errico qu'ils sont
voilà du cnrs de bordeaux qui aussi
conteste ça un bon et puis ça me semble
normal ccc pas stériles d'avoir un débat
c'est pas stérile d'alimenter le débat
mais après il voit là les contre
arguments ont aussi des aussi des
critiques qu'on peut appliquer aux
contre-arguments donc la première
critique donc c'est que le registre
fossile mais bon le voilà le registre
fossile comme j'ai dit les plus tôt il
est tout autant en faveur quand des
faveur d'une origine sud africaine je
pense qu'il est même plutôt en faveur
d'une origine sud-africaine au vu de la
littérature récente ensuite une analyse
mitochondrial donc le poème c'est que
l'adn mitochondrial n'est transmis que
par la mer donc quand on veut analyser
les gènes d'une population on préfère
analyser la totalité des jeunes d'une
population puisque et pas seulement
l'adn mitochondrial puisque le l'adn
mitochondrial on oublie complètement la
moitié de la population qui est la
population paternel voilà ça je trouve
que c'est un argument qui est valable
à première vue mais le fait est que
l'adn mitochondrial d'une ça permet de
il est beaucoup mieux connu donc ça
permet d'avoir plus de données dans l'
analyse phylogénétique et l'adn
mitochondrial aussi ça permet justement
d'éliminer la line et la lignée
patrilinéaire donc la lignée paternelle
ce qui permet du coup de l'enlever aussi
du bruit donc donc il n'ya pas vrai je
crois pas qu'il y ait vraiment de moyen
de déterminer si on enlève du bruit ou
du signal en enlevant la lignée
paternelle
donc c'est possible que ce soit du bruit
en fait qu'il soit parti et passe et pas
du signal donc oui et non je suis pas
sûr je suis pas sûr que ce soit un très
très bon argument de dire c'est que basé
que sur l'adn mitochondrial que l'adn
mitochondrial c'est déjà vachement plus
de données
cd c vhc une certaine c'est une immense
quantité de données je suis même pas sûr
qu'on ait de du génome nucléaire
suffisamment de génome nucléaire pour
compenser cette quantité de données
on a beaucoup plus d'individus pour
lesquelles l'un des aides mitochondrial
est connue quoi tout simplement
et puis à tout simplement que si cette
étude est vraiment commencé à vraiment
commencé comme étant une étude de l'ap
le type f zero bain de toute façon c'est
forcément l'adn mitochondrial qu'ils
allaient regarder un donc
donc si si l'étude a commencé comme une
étude haplotype mitochondrial bas on va
pas regarder autre chose que l'adn
mitochondrial on repart garder l'adn
nucléaire ou les génomes complets quoi
et puis le deuxième argument qui est
intéressant et qui est développée c'est
l'argument des migrations
parce que les populations humaines elles
sont certes installé aujourd'hui enfin
ces populations humaines de kohistan
sont peut-être installé dans la moitié
sud de l'afrique
aujourd'hui oui mais l'été tel il y a
deux cent mille ans et ça et ça et ça c
est ça c'est quand même c'est quand même
une question intéressante donc on sait
notamment que aujourd'hui on trouve
l'écho et sane surtout dans le kalahari
mais ce n'était pas forcément le cas il
ya
il ya ne serait-ce que mille ans de cela
avant la colonisation l'écho et sane il
avait une distribution qui était
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus dispatcher
on a retrouvé notamment bas en afrique
du sud
jusque dans la côte jusque vers la côte
sud de l'afrique on l'a trouvé dans la
région du cap
on les trouvait autour du lesotho et
aujourd'hui il y en a plus de séquences
and donc je rappelle ses les bushmen les
bushmen typiquement c'est l'afrique du
sud est aujourd'hui on les trouve plus
que dans le kalahari
donc ça c'est il ya une raison toute
simple c'est parce que c'est un désert
et que c'est à peu près le seul endroit
où on veut bien les laisser vivre en
gros ce qui est très triste mais voilà
il ya donc ça et il ya donc ça c'est
l'immigration qui sont très récentes
mais après il ya eu d'autres migration
qui sont plus anciennes et notamment des
migrations qui ont eu lieu il ya
quarante mille ans 50000 enfin bref il
le disputent un petit peu dans le dans
l'article mais pour eux ce sont des
dispersions à partir de leur centre
d'origine du centre d'origine dont il
faut l'hypothèse au centre au milieu de
l'afrique
au milieu du sud de l'afrique donc mais
bon voilà il faut pas perdre de vue la
possibilité qui a pu aussi avoir des
mouvements et notamment des mouvements
depuis l'afrique de l'est jusqu'au sud
de l'afrique par exemple ça c'est si les
mouvements ont pu avoir avoir lieu dans
un sens d'après leurs modèles leur
modèle environnemental
ces mouvements auraient pu avoir une
aurait pu avoir lieu dans l'autre sens
donc voilà et puis il ya cette critique
il ya cette critique qui dit qu'on
demande aux grandes revues scientifiques
d'avoir des des titres tapageurs bon je
pense que les gens qui font ces
critiques là en fait ils ont eux-mêmes
publié justement dans hitch heures quoi
donc
donc bon on est on est tous sujets à ça
je veux dire les clés les titres plus ta
clique ça marche pas que dans la presse
ça marche aussi dans la littérature
scientifique
là pour le coup c'est vrai que je trouve
le titre un peu
là pour le coup le titre ça aurait dû
être plutôt une étude des populations l0
quoi des populations dans la pelote ipl
0 quoi parce que c'est vraiment comme ça
on voit très bien que c'est comme ça que
cette étude a commencé donc quel
pourcentage pour conclure quel
pourcentage de confiance peut-on
accorder à ce résultat
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba je sais pas je sais
pas les résultats en soi sont pas
inintéressants ils sont pas mauvais
c'est juste que les conclusions sont
sont pas adaptés finalement aux données
qui sont étudiées donc les résultats 80%
les conclusions moins de 50% je pense
puis alors là la presse c'est même pas
la peine de la lire voilà les rapports
de presse par contre l'assaut sur la fp
tous à vous laisser tomber parce que si
déjà l'article arrive pas lui-même à
rendre ça bien comme il faut
faut pas s'attendre à ce que la presse
en face en face de bonnes choses voilà
c'était mon analyse vite fait et à chaud
je viens seulement de lire l'article à
l'instant dites moi ce que vous en avez
pensé
n'hésitez pas à poser des questions
j'essaierai d'y répondre ou au moins de
vous envoyer vers quelqu'un qui sera
capable d'y répondre et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour un nouveau un jour un
fossile